probably no other creatures on the
planet have struck as much fear and all
in our hearts
as the dinosaurs
[Music]
the earliest dinosaurs appeared about
245
million years ago during the triassic
period
when most of the earth's land masses
were still joined together as the
supercontinent pangaea over millions of
years pangaea split apart causing the
dinosaurs to become separated for the
very first time
this led the reptiles to adapt to their
specific habitats and diversify giving
rise to many new dinosaur species
according to some estimates more than
one thousand species of dinosaurs have
roamed the earth
all dinosaurs descended from reptiles
called archosaurs
from there dinosaurs branched out into
two major groups sauroskiya and
ornithischia based on the shape and
orientation of their pelvis
in sariskian dinosaurs such as
tyrannosaurus rex and brachiosaurus the
pelvis's pubis bone faces forward and
down
in ornithischian dinosaurs such as
stegosaurus and hadrosaurs the pubis
bone faces backward and down
across both groups dinosaurs varied
greatly in size
some were small like comp signatus which
was barely larger than a chicken
whereas others were gigantic like
dreadnatus which was 85 feet long and
weighed 65 tons
making it the largest land animal to
have ever lived
dinosaur diets varied as well
herbivores like hadrosaurs evolved to
have specialized teeth for grinding
tough plant material
carnivores made up roughly 40
of dinosaur species
some predators like the raptor deonicus
even hunted in packs
social behaviors were also found in
other dinosaurs
footprints and trackways indicate that
some of the ancient reptiles traveled
together
evidence also shows that herds may have
made annual visits to certain sites to
lay their eggs
but by around 66 million years ago most
dinosaurs died out and the reason why is
still a mystery
[Music]
the most well-known explanation is an
asteroid strike
but a multitude of factors may have
contributed to this extinction
in fact the dinosaur population was
already in severe decline by the time
the asteroid struck
however
several dinosaur species survived and
some of which evolved to become today's
birds
the world has never again seen land
creatures as great as the dinosaurs
but through their descendants and
fossils left behind
their legacy lives on
[Music]
[Music]
you